[Music]
this week on
brian ross investigates the white house
as conspiracy central
i ask that you get checked out
the president spreading the unfounded
conspiracy theory that tv news host joe
scarborough
may have murdered one of his staffers
when he was in congress
hopefully someday people are going to
find out certainly a very suspicious
situation investigative reporter mike
isikoff of yahoo news
gets to the bottom of it this is a
completely
baseless conspiracy theory and his
exclusive interview with the husband of
the woman who died from a pre-existing
heart condition
when there's a raw open wound
every time it starts to heal up it gets
a little tougher
plus the amazing video of a u.s delta
force operation
to rescue hostages from isis in iraq
that led to the country's highest
military honor for the man who led the
mission
pat you embody the righteous glory of
american valor
all at the very time the president was
being accused of calling members of the
military
losers and suckers and our winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite
should bob woodward have gone public
sooner
with the president's revealing comments
to be honest with you sure i want you to
i wanted to
i wanted to always play it down from the
law and crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live and youtube live i'm brian
ross joined tonight as always by my
colleague
rhonda schwartz from the law and crime
network and ryan we begin with the white
house as conspiracy
central and one of the more outrageous
conspiracies being spun by the president
is an allegation against one of his most
vocal critics tv host joe scarborough
suggesting that scarborough when he was
in congress somehow
murdered a female staff aide who worked
for him rodda
that's right brian and at the heart of
this story is the
tragic death of a young woman laurie
clasudus
some 20 years ago when she worked for
joe scarborough when he was then a
congressman
and as always the question with
conspiracies is how and whether
to try to put them to rest how and
whether to stamp out
a preposterous lie as msnbc host joe
scarborough a former republican
congressman from florida
stepped up his criticism of president
trump on his program
mourning joe i don't look at donald
trump
and say why can't he help himself why
can't he fix himself why can't he be
at least competent because
he has proven time and time again he
just can't do it
that just suggests that you're not well
right now you still
don't get it the president fired back
calling on twitter with no evidence to
back it up
for scarborough to be investigated for
the murder of a female staff member
laurie clasudus when scarborough was in
congress almost 20 years ago
the president's tweet to his 80 million
followers gave huge exposure
and new life to a baseless lingering
right-wing conspiracy theory
about scarborough and his former aide
and scarborough was outraged
and you actually tweeted something uh
extraordinarily cruel and i know you
meant to be extraordinarily cruel to me
by attacking me by bringing up a
conspiracy theory
that has lived in the gutters
of the internet for some time now
but just like the seth rich conspiracy
murder
that was pushed by your allies
you don't understand the pain you cause
you cause to families who have already
lost
a loved one i ask
that you get checked out i ask that you
take a rest
i ask that you take care of yourself
maybe let
mike pence run things for the next week
you're not well
we're joined now by mike izakoff the
chief investigative correspondent for
yahoo news
and host of the podcast conspiracy land
which deals in this latest episode
with these joe scarborough allegations
and rumors
and mike let me start by asking you
sometimes conspiracies are built on
a small grain of truth and distorted in
this case is there any grain of truth
uh in short no this
is a completely baseless conspiracy
theory
that actually was originally cooked up
by
die-hard democratic partisans in 2001 as
a way to stick it to a then
sitting republican congressman in fact
it was all baseless the police
investigated there was
no evidence of foul play whatsoever
she there was a a medical autopsy that
found she had an
undiagnosed heart ailment that caused
her to faint lose consciousness bang her
head
then years later nearly two decades
later
when donald trump is having his blood
feud with joe scarborough because of his
criticism on the morning joe show trump
revives
this baseless conspiracy theory starts
tweeting it left and right there was
nothing to support it yet it went out
to the more than 80 million followers of
donald trump on twitter
then gets picked up by the q anon
conspiracy crowd
and it's really sort of a case study
in how baseless conspiracy theories can
get
traction in you know this new age of
social media
thanks to the president of the united
states
and yet he's continued to double down
and suggest there's something suspicious
listen to what he had to say at the
white house news conference
the second question was about your
tweets about the the woman who died who
you're
suggesting that joe scarborough was
responsible
yeah a lot of people suggest that and uh
hopefully someday people are going to
find out certainly a very suspicious
situation very sad very sad and very
suspicious
so mike what's the reaction from
laurie's uh husband
to see trump doing all this you talked
to him yes i did this is the first
interview he's
ever done i mean he is appalled
and distraught that these
uh conspiracy theories about the death
of his wife
continue to get circulation out there
they cause
pain he says at one point it's like a
raw open
wound when there's a raw
open wound every time it starts to heal
up it gets a little tougher
here comes another one of these events
in this that sort of peels the scab back
and re-exposes it
and here we are 19 years later i should
not be having to worry about
having a fresh open wound on this you
know
this whole story this whole conspiracy
everything else
it actually has nothing to do with her
she's just an asterisk she's just a
footnote she's what gives it a little
sizzle
and and it's unfair you know her
her life her being her goodness
will never ever be remembered
it's only gonna be all this other crap
it's just been unfair it's just been
completely unfair it's
this woman deserves so much better
than i had or have the ability
to do for her and you know he made
this poignant plea to jack
dorsey the ceo of twitter in a letter
last may
pleading with him to take down the
president's
faults and uh tweets about the death of
his wife
and then and then dorsey essentially at
the stockholders meeting said we don't
we don't censor public officials we also
believe that it's important that people
have
conversations around what's happening
especially with our global leaders what
was the
husband's reaction to that we played it
for him
and he says that's bull
well that's a bunch of bullshit
it's bullshit it's this was not an
issue that was important to our society
whatsoever and finally mike let me ask
you why do americans so
love conspiracy theories well
that's an excellent question i think
that um
we are all fascinated by them because
they provide an explanation
for events that are at times
uh murky and uh uh um
and and unclear and to
come up with a good juicy conspiracy
theory
that explains it all especially if it
fits one's political narrative
and this is a classic example remember
who pushed
who first pushed it it was democratic
partisans because
you know a way of taking a a a
of taking a swipe at a republican
congressman it
furthered their political agenda and
then years later it migrates to the
political right
and uh donald trump picks it up and
you know his followers jump all over it
and uh so you know these conspiracy
theories when they
fit our preconceived political
narratives and prejudices
uh really can catch on
all right michael isikoff chief
investigative correspondent yahoo news
and host of the podcast conspiracy land
michael thank you so much for being with
us here tonight
thank you brian
coming up next honor and dishonor at the
white house
when we come back you're watching the
law and crime trial network
next the commander-in-chief and the
white house
approach to those who have given their
lives we begin with the story of an
american hero who was honored last week
at the white house by a president
who has disparaged openly those who have
given their lives for their country
our mission was to conduct a hostage
rescue raid on october 22nd
2015 in huizhou iraq for this mission i
was assistant team leader
my team was responsible for one of the
buildings
that the hostels were being held in what
was significant is that there were
freshly dug graves
and if we didn't action this target then
the hostages will probably be executed
at that point it was our duty to bring
those men home
[Music]
we cut the locks on the prison doors and
opened the cell and
you know over 25 about 25 hostages in
one cell and
probably 11 in the other and
you see their faces light up and
they're being liberated and some are
crying
some are excited and while it's going on
there's still an intense firefight
going on another building you can see
the flames you hear
all the explosions going on pat you
embody the
righteous glory of american valor
it is now my privilege to present
sergeant major
thomas patrick payne with the
congressional
medal of honor
to talk about this more we're joined now
by karen greenberg of the center on
national security at the fordham school
of law in new york
and by retired navy commander guy
snodgrass who
is a former speechwriter for the
secretary of defense james mattis
a top gun pilot himself and out just
this week
his new book top game top guns top ten
and commando snogwrest let me start with
you how do you reconcile
the president giving this medal of honor
with what he's reportedly said about the
military
behind their backs well i think always
there's the just the reality that what
you do in public doesn't always align
with what you say or how you feel in
private
i'm glad to see that the president did
recognize the service member and of
course i think the service member
himself would tell you that he's
simply the individual receiving the
award or the recognition in this case
uh but that you know this is a a
recognition that's really
reflects more on the men and women that
he has served alongside during his
entirety of his career but it's great to
see him being recognized
karen grigmur let me ask you this uh the
president's comments have received a lot
of publicity a lot of attention
how are people in the military reacting
to all of that
i think that there's um a growing schism
between the president and the military
it didn't start just with the atlantic
article
it's been persistent throughout his
actually administration
he's been to kind of two-faced towards
the military
on the one hand he loves the pomp and
circumstance of the military
he likes surrounding himself with
generals in the early days of his
administration
but he doesn't like to be tethered and
in the wake of george
floyd in the wake of the protests and
now with the election
chaos pending the military is really
taking a step back
from the president on a number of issues
uh
discrimination being one of them not
wanting to interfere
in domestic politics being another one
of them so i think you see
a schism that is only going to intensify
rather than die down or wane
commendo snogwrest a question for you
from rhonda schwartz
rhonda we've seen your former boss
general mattis
and general kelly comment about this in
they've had written comments do you
think they'll speak out publicly during
this
election cycle i'm not sure whether or
not they're going to speak publicly but
i do i have a
kind of a sneaky suspicion that that's
what we're going to see more of in
october
bob woodward's book was also released
today as one of the breaking
tidbits from that book was the fact that
he quotes secretary of defense
james mattis as along with former
director of national intelligence dan
coats is saying that
they're deeply concerned by president
trump's actions and they
and they're wondering with bob woodward
whether or not they have a
an obligation to step forward and speak
truth to power and also to share what
they know with the american public and
so i think as we get
further into this election cycle as we
get our make our way into october you're
much more likely to see
individuals who served in this very
administration stepping forward
with their feelings about a second trump
administration term
commander snodgrass you talking new new
book about leadership lessons learned
from the cockpit
how would you assess the leadership of
donald trump as the commander-in-chief
well i think going back to some of the
points we made previously when you
take a look at how the military
approaches leadership and the concept of
leadership
it's it's a profession of arms it's
driven by
adherence to legality staying within the
ethical midfield
putting service before herself and so
one of the my favorite terms
of all time is that a person's actions
speak
far louder than their words ever can and
so that's where president trump is now
having some difficulty with the military
is the fact that
although sometimes he will praise the
military in public his words in private
betray his true feelings
and also the way he responds is not what
the military members have been led
have been trained their entire careers
as how a good leader
should act or should behave and that's
the fundamental disconnect that exists
between president trump and the military
he leaves leads
let alone many of the other members of
the professional part of the
administration
and karen greenberg what's the impact
what's the result of this kind of a
schism between
the military and the commander-in-chief
it puts the military yeah it puts the
military in a i think a very
difficult situation and you've seen i
don't know if you saw i'm sure you did
see that
um a number of national security
officials signed a letter
recently uh disavowing trump and
supporting biden
you've seen more and more military
people uh come out and say
things that are very strongly against uh
the president including admiral mcraven
who called it shameful and called them
being embarrassed i mean
i think that this is the the idea that
the military
can stay separate from politics is a
fundamental principle
of how the military operates and now
they're being put into position
where they really have to distinguish
what is politics and what is patriotism
and i think you're seeing more and more
of them identify with the idea that
patriotism means standing up for the
values
they don't have to even put trump's name
on it but there are certain
fundamental values and they've been put
in this position and my guess is i
i agree i think we're going to see more
and more statements
and not very oblique i think some very
direct statements
talking about the way forward for this
country
all right karen greenberg from fordham
school thank you very much commander
guy snodgrass thank you both for being
here tonight really appreciate it
coming up next the winners and losers
this week in the media
take a look at bob woodward's new book
rage
back now with winners and losers this
week in the media as chosen by the
editors at mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of
mediaite which like the law and crime
network is part of the dan abrams media
empire
and they let's start and talk only about
bob woodward his new book
rage an incredible tour de force with
all those
on the record interviews with president
trump all on tape
here's a clip of one of the things the
president talked about with mr woodward
it's also more deadly than your you know
your even your strenuous flus for
this is more deadly this is five per
you know this is five percent versus one
percent and less than one percent
you know so this is deadly stuff
well i think bob really to be honest
with you sir i want you to i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down
yes because i don't want to create a
panic
so aidan no doubt a big winner his book
long awaited made a big
impact yeah so it's a it's a pretty huge
release from bob woodward i have the
book here uh it's called
rage it follows his previous book about
uh the president of donald trump's
administration called fear
uh now the difference between the two
books is that president trump did not
participate in fear
uh as opposed to rage the new book where
trump gave
18 on the record interviews to bob
woodward um
and bob woodward you know you hear in
the audio tapes that woodward has
released
from these interviews you can hear him
clearly saying that he's going to start
his recorder and that he's
that the president is on the record and
the president proceeds to
you know dish out some pretty remarkable
things about
the way his administration has responded
to the coronavirus pandemic
that was the big splashy headline that
came out last week
from this book before the book was even
published
that basically the president back in
february knew
the dangers of the virus uh said that it
was incredibly deadly
as in that clip that you played and that
later admitted in early march that he
wanted to
downplay it deliberately because he
didn't want to cause a panic
now there's a lot of flaws in you know
the leader of a country saying
uh that they wanted to downplay a deadly
pandemic perhaps by misleading the
american public
because they didn't want to create a
panic of some sort
um but it was a really remarkable
headline from woodward's book
uh it was one of many uh there's a ton
of really interesting reporting on
for example the secretary of defense
james mattis
who left the administration over
disagreements with trump about how he
thinks that the president is a danger to
the constitution
um and you know it's hard for the
president to dismiss this book
because he gave 18 on the record
interviews to it and in fact he was
asked about the book on fox and friends
this morning
and uh did not dismiss it as fake news
he said he read the book that he thought
it was boring i'm sure a lot of people
would disagree
um but he didn't contest uh its
reporting so
i think it's certainly a win for bob
woodward
and in just 10 seconds left here uh was
there a mistake he made in not releasing
it sooner there's an argument to be made
there you know he was reporting this for
a book
um it would i think you know at the time
he said he wasn't sure whether it was
true what trump was saying about
the virus being as deadly as it was um
you know there's a debate
i think he's defended himself well on
that front
all right aida mclaughlin thank you so
much for joining us as
always very interesting and thank all of
you for joining us
and thanks to our team at long crime for
guineas on the air
and of course off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
you